if you hate Fresno so much why'd you
come back obviously because I've made a
series of poor life decisions I thank
you very like teaching at that
fancy-pants school it was but then I got
fired because it's a bunch of people my
sister's back and I just let her save my
place out of this job she's still
fragile I'm a sex addict that's a thing
I was like made up by Tiger Woods or
something how many guys you think you've
been with like 100
I think you've ever been in love I'm not
good with emotions really I've never
been to a wedding I went to one but it
doesn't really count because we elope my
life is crazy you're a maid in Fresno my
sister's a liar she's selfish she's
ungrateful and she can't get her life
together I just killed someone is anyone
here doctor you killed an Olympian only
if you consider hammer throw a sport
which you're a sociopath you deserve
some dignity have one deserve some
dignity we want 25,000 to get out of
this butt crack there's no way we can
come up with 25k in three days we're
friends no I need you to come over here
right now and open this Packard to start
I need all the cash now who's greater
deal with this robbing sex shop
you know who would have loved that Oprah
Winfrey's America
siblings can really sink each other you
know
bunch of porn once in a while but most
of those women slaves they put them in a
box as should be though that's no those
are the managers
see Anita's Carla's wish my sleepin a
party who beset by young machine broken
Sydney image the photo team / - Marvin -
the snake Nicky Berlin